si vous êtes créateur si vous cherchez
un smartphone polyvalent pour de la
photo de la vidéo avec un superbe écran
qui sera puissant pour faire tourner
beaucoup de jeux et un tarif maîtrisé
dans le milieu de gamme et bien je vous
présente aujourd'hui le Honor 90
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui réalisait en
partenariat avec Honor qui m'a dit gros
est-ce que tu peux venir tester notre
nouveau Flac cheap dans le milieu de
gamme le Honor 90 bien évidemment j'aime
la marque pourquoi parce que déjà c'est
une marque évolue énormément avec une
très grosse gamme qui avant était avec
Huawei qui vous le savez aujourd'hui
n'est plus avec Huawei indépendante et
aller service Google et ça on a mais
c'est très très bien et qui propose
beaucoup de choses avec beaucoup
d'innovation notamment au niveau de la
photo de la vidéo donc aujourd'hui on va
regarder ce Honor 90 en 7 points 7
points top cette raison de venir choisir
sur une heure 90 allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
le Honor 90 c'est avant tout un très bel
écran et ça c'est quand même supra
important un grand écran qui incurvé des
quatre côtés c'est à dire un curvé sur
la gauche sur la droite bien évidemment
mais également sur le haut et sur le bas
alors vous me direz un écran de côté
c'est bien mignon mais ça sert à quoi et
bien en fait c'est pour apporter plus
d'immersion lorsque vous allez venir
regarder du contenu on a l'impression un
peu plus dedans alors c'est pas non plus
le truc mais on se jette dans l'écran ça
nous saute pas aux yeux mais pour autant
je trouve ça très joli alors au-delà du
côté très immersif il y a un côté aussi
esthétique qui est très sympa et qui en
fait un smartphone qui est super
agréable à dire regardez on se parle ici
d'une très grosse dalle de 6,7 pouces
très grosse diagonale alors l'intérêt
d'avoir une très grosse diagonale comme
ça et bien c'est quoi c'est une fois de
plus pour l'immersion vaut mieux
regarder un contenu film série Netflix
jouer à un jeu vous allez voir qu'on a
de la performance on peut venir jouer à
des jeux ici sans aucun problème et bien
il y a la place c'est grand c'est beau
ça me plaît vous avez également un tout
petit poinçon qui situe là donc rien qui
vient bien gêner le visionnage de vos
films et de vos séries ça c'est pas
nouveau et on a l'habitude donc ça
fonctionne comme il est incurvé des
quatre côtés il permet d'avoir aussi une
bonne préhension on tient très très bien
le produit en main donc là-dessus il y a
aucun souci vous allez voir que le
design aussi à l'arrière il joue mais
sans le regarde un peu plus tard dans la
vidéo après je vous passe un peu
l'histoire on est sur un smartphone
spécifique on est sur la molette la
molette ça veut dire quoi ça veut donc
dire que dès que vous avez du noir
quelque part sur votre écran et bien hop
là notamment si vous passez sur un thème
sombre et bien là comme tous les pixels
noirs sont des pixels éteint ça permet
de pousser plus loin l'autonomie taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
Hertz ça aussi c'est très très bien pour
tout ce qui va être expérience de gaming
sur certains jeux c'est cool alors après
je vous passe le truc il y a plusieurs
modes on peut être en dynamique qui va
le gérer automatiquement soit vous
laissez tout le temps 120 soit vous le
mettez en 90 soit vous le mettez en 60
c'est vous qui choisissez et l'autre
point moi qui m'intéresse vachement ça
va être tout ce qui va être confort des
yeux et sommeil vous avez l'affichage
nocturne circadien lorsque vous arrivez
sur des heures un peu plus tard dites au
moment d'aller vous coucher il va venir
passer sur une température de couleur un
peu plus sur le jaune ça évite de
retarder la production de mélatonine au
niveau de votre cerveau et donc ça
permet l'endormissement ça pose pas de
problème donc ça c'est un truc qui
vachement important à venir activer que
je vous conseille réellement alors il y
a le confort des yeux qu'on peut mettre
activé en permanence à jaunit tout le
temps et on choisit c'est pas
nécessairement ce que je vais venir
faire mais après il y a d'autres trucs
qu'on fait Honor ici d'un point de vue
purement technologique et qui sont
vachement bien vous avez notamment le
taille de Mick gaming qui va venir
ajuster la luminosité automatiquement en
extérieur lorsqu'il fait très beau et
bien il va monter jusqu'à maximum 1600
Nitz qui fait que vous pourrez lire voir
votre contenu sans aucun problème à
l'extérieur et puis l'autre point qui
est super important lorsque vous venez
regarder en faible luminosité si vous
voulez éviter d'avoir de la fatigue
oculaire avec une fréquence d'affichage
vous en rendrez pas compte vous mais vos
yeux d'en souffriront avec une fréquence
d'affichage qui sera trop basse et qui
au bout d'un moment fera que voilà j'ai
les yeux exposé ça fonctionne plus et
bien eux ils ont une fréquence
d'affichage qui va jusqu'à
3840 Hertz ça veut dire que c'est
quasiment imperceptible pour vos yeux
pas de fatigue oculaire c'est marqué ici
vous avez la gradation PWM à ultra haute
fréquence il vous marque le sentiment
réduit de l'écran améliore le confort
des yeux ils ont même l'obtention de la
certification par toy reinland sans
sentiment atteignant le niveau de
gradation sans risque et ça c'est
chouette sans oublier la techno dynamide
vide qui donnera des couleurs encore
plus éclatantes plus la liste et un
écran qui a eu la certification Gold
chez dxmark avec un score de 140 qui en
fait un top écran dans sa catégorie
alors le deuxième point c'est la
performance je vous le disais tout à
l'heure avoir un bel écran pour venir
jouer à des jeux c'est bien mais
derrière il faut que ça suive vous avez
un stand dragon 7 Gen 1 derrière qui
fonctionne super bien alors bien
évidemment c'est un processeur qui est à
la fois 5g et wifi 6 qui a 12 g et 7
giga de mémoire virtuelle c'est ce
qu'ils appellent la Honor RAM turbo qui
vous permet de monter un 19 Go de RAM
grâce à cette mémoire virtuelle alors
cette mémoire virtuelle elle va
fonctionner si vous avez du stockage qui
est dispo parce qu'il va venir taper
dedans mais ce qui est super intéressant
c'est que lorsque vous avez besoin de
performance et de bouse de performance
vous savez ce qu'il faut sous le capot
en plus de ça vous avez 512 Go de
stockage donc en termes de stockage pour
venir mettre tous vos jeux dedans vos
films vos séries vos musiques vos photos
vos vidéos tous vos souvenirs et bien
vous n'aurez absolument ici aucun
problème vous oubliez qu'en plus vous
avez un refroidissement avec chambre à
vapeur qui va venir dissiper la chaleur
donc pour les grandes sessions gaming
globalement ça va aller le troisième
point c'est cette grosse batterie de
5000 ça c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
alors je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il y a plusieurs choses qui vont venir
jouer au niveau de l'autonomie de votre
smartphone il y a effectivement bien
l'écran le fait d'être sur du OLED de la
molette et de switcher sur un thème son
vous allez venir économiser au niveau de
la batterie le processeur également s'il
est énergivore pas trop énergivore il
est technologie de rame de stockage et
compagnie mais derrière il faut quand
même une grosse batterie il faut pas mal
de cellules pour venir stocker toute
cette énergie et ici avec 5000 milliards
globalement vous êtes peinard donc ça
c'est chouette sans oublier que en plus
il est compatible super charge 66 watts
de Honor on regrettera juste qu'il ne
soit pas présent dans la boîte si vous
voulez profiter de la super charge 66
watts et bien va falloir venir soit
utiliser un chargeur déjà compatible 66
watts que vous avez déjà soit venir
l'acheter directement sur le site de
Honor je vous mets un lien en bas dans
la description le quatrième point et qui
me plaît beaucoup c'est la partie photo
parce que vous avez trois capteurs
photos dont le capteur principal qui est
de 200 mégapixels qui va se situer juste
en haut ici en dessous vous avez un
ultra grand temps de macro de 12
mégapixels puis une caméra de profondeur
de 2 mégapixels bon un flash en dessous
ça c'est plus anecdotique mais aussi une
caméra de selfie de 50 mégapixels de un
jour ça vous sort des photos qui sont
magnifiques avec beaucoup de détails
détails dans le ciel détails dans la mer
sur le bateau sur les montagnes de corps
et on peut venir zoomer dedans pour
venir recadrer alors on va pas venir
zoomer non plus à l'infini sans propre
évidemment ça fonctionne plus c'est
normal mais il y a des limites physiques
à ce moment-là il faut venir passer
directement en photo 200 mégapixels pour
venir regrouper dedans puisque ici on a
une technologie de pixel binning lorsque
vous shootez ça vous regroupe plusieurs
pixels pour capter plus de luminosité
plus de détails donc si vous voulez
avoir une photo en 200 mégapixels il
faut directement venir l'activer dans
votre smartphone regardez-moi cette
image là avec ce ponton qui part
invitation voyage ça donne vraiment
envie d'y aller sur le grand angle mais
également sur l'ultra grand-angle vous
voyez vous avez beaucoup de détails au
niveau du ciel au niveau de la nature
derrière une petite différence a un peu
plus terne le capteur sera un peu moins
bon que celui de 200 mégapixels vous
pouvez le voir notamment en regardant
ici l'herbe qui est plus verte avec plus
de détails et lorsqu'on passe sur
l'ultra grand-angle et bien c'est un peu
plus foncé l'herbe ressort un peu moins
on est malgré tout sur un smartphone ou
Honor a dû faire des choix au niveau du
budget donc on peut pas mettre les
meilleurs capteurs partout si vous
voulez les meilleurs capteurs vous
passez sur la gamme Magic au dessus et
là c'est une toute autre histoire
regardez la panorama magnifique on a
envie d'aller se baigner sur avant-angle
le boulot est aussi vraiment bien fait
j'adore les détails qu'on peut venir
retrouver ici vous voyez au niveau de
cet arbre regardez ça marche bon la
macro ça a jamais été trop mon truc et
je suis pas non plus extrêmement fan et
ici sur des couchers de soleil je trouve
ça aussi une fois de plus très très
jolie ça fonctionne vraiment sur le
contre-jour vous voyez même pour venir
trouver des boîtes aux lettres dans les
artisans vous voyez là c'est pareil ça
fonctionne bien quand il est plus exposé
à côté un peu plus sombre tout est là
aucun problème et en photo de nuit il
arrivera aussi à sortir des images qui
sont très sympas le mode portrait et
aussi maîtrisé grâce à ce capteur de 2
mégapixels regardez-moi ça super joli
c'est ultra grand angle aussi et la
caméra de selfie fait également le taf
pour avoir de très bons résultats le
cinquième point ça va être la vidéo avec
plein d'options différentes pour venir
filmer bien évidemment avec votre
capteur de 200 mégapixels pour avoir le
meilleur résultat avec la vidéo 4K même
en selfie et ça globalement c'est
vachement cool en profitant en plus d'un
grand angle de 100 degrés mais également
de la vidéo avec intelligence
artificielle avec je vous le disais tout
à l'heure de la vidéo HDR le mode multi
vidéo mais également le solocal dont je
vous ai déjà parlé l'année dernière
comme ce téléphone est fait pour les
créatif et bien je peux venir filmer
avec ma caméra arrière là je suis en 4K
donc vous pouvez me dire filmer sans
aucun problème faire du vlog vous filmez
vous balader alors là j'ai mis sur une
perche j'ai pas un drap aussi long que
ça mais vous pouvez poser sur un trépied
le mettre sur une perche bref venir
faire de la création de contenu comme
vous le souhaitez mega également
d'autres modes qui existent alors avant
de vous montrer d'autres modes je vous
montre ce qu'on peut faire sur la caméra
de selfie qui est planqué juste là on
peut également venir se filmer sans
aucun problème on a également le mode
multi vidéo je viens de filmer sur la
caméra de selfie et je peux filmer ce
qui à l'arrière ça c'est vachement bien
lorsque vous faites une interview que
vous voulez venir monter quelque chose
ce n'est regarder il y a ça là-bas alors
après je peux venir changer
l'incrustation lorsque je me balade tu
peux mettre moi tout en bas en
incrustation et laisser le reste pour
venir vous montrer ce qui se passe ça je
peux le faire donc ça c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal je peux également
switcher vous mettre la caméra grand
angle et la caméra
ultra
d'angle peut venir ensuite changer et
mettre que la caméra arrière dans ce
mode là et ensuite le mettre que la
caméra avant alors vous me direz quel
est l'intérêt de mettre que la caméra
arrière ou que la caméra avant et bien
c'est qu'à tout moment et bien je peux
venir switcher comme ça et faire un
espèce de live ou je viens de filmer
j'ai montré les choses sans venir
m'embêter tout ça sur la même prison
donc à côté extrêmement pratique et
extrêmement malin pour tous les
créateurs de contenu et puis un autre
qui est assez marrant c'est le Film
instantané lorsque vous avez une vidéo
qui soit votre smartphone et bien vous
pouvez cliquer dessus et lui il va vous
proposer une création avec des template
pour venir améliorer tout ça vous avez
des modèles de la musique des mini apps
vous voyez vous choisissez Happy Hour
confortable amour simple pretty bref
vous avez différents modèles pour venir
totalement sublimer vos vidéos ici donc
pour du contenu créatif ou vous voulez
pas vous embêter à venir faire des
montages sur des logiciels ici et ça et
bien lui il va venir vous proposer des
template pour venir habiller vos vidéos
très facilement vous avez également du
choix de musique alors pour des
questions de droit d'auteur bien
évidemment je vais pas vous les mettre
mais vous avez quand même pas mal de
choses les Minias 5,7 5,8 bref il y a
plein de choses il y a du choix plus à
conclusion ici vous voyez vous propose
une vidéo qui va être montée vous pouvez
la découper vous pouvez venir changer
des choses modifier le volume trier bref
et partager très facilement et très
rapidement vos contenus sur les réseaux
sociaux sixième point non des moindres
c'est son design comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure il est incurvé à l'avance
sur les quatre côtés il est juste super
canon mais à l'arrière il est également
incurvé on a donc une très bonne
prévention c'est un smartphone contient
très très facilement et très bien normal
donc ça c'est quand même vachement cool
en plus de ça avec ces deux blocs
optiques sur le côté je trouve très joli
on va retrouver le branding au nord ici
sur le côté alors ça sort pas toujours
très très bien la caméra mais moi j'ai
le vert émeraude qui est il faut le dire
ma couleur préférée vous avez le choix
soit avec le vert émeraude soit avec le
Midnight Black Midnight Black c'est bien
c'est beau c'est l'intemporel c'est du
noir mais je préfère cette couleur là
que je trouve beaucoup plus jolie sans
oublier il faut leur exclusif sur le
site de Honor est uniquement sur le site
de Honor Diamonds silver qui est juste
super joli d'ailleurs dites-moi vous
quel est votre couleur préférée qu'elle
serait votre couleur préférée autre
point intéressant au niveau de celui là
c'est que grâce à ce design là et bien
vous n'avez absolument aucune trace de
doigt puis ça
[Musique]
financement qui va jusqu'au 19 juillet
et jusqu'au 19 juillet uniquement donc
allez-y comme ça vous serez pas déçu
donc vous voyez c'est un smartphone qui
est super complet intéressant double nan
aussi mon adieu NFC du Bluetooth 5.2
bref il a une fiche technique qui est
très complète le capteur d'empreintes
digitale sous l'écran il est bien il est
beau il est pratique je l'aime bien vous
le dire vous ce que vous en pensez
comment est-ce que vous trouvez sur une
heure 90 est-ce qu'il vous plaît vous
plaît pas vous voyez pas vous marquez
bien évidemment tout ça dans les
commentaires et nous on se retrouve très
bientôt pour continuer à parler bien
évidemment de Honor mais pas que de
plein de choses à voir c'est génial je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt des bisous Ciao